hey guys it's Justine and today we have
got some of the Microsoft goodies that
were just announced I was there in New
York for their big press event so today
we're gonna be checking out the new
Microsoft Surface laptop this is a
15-inch and the new Microsoft Surface
pro with their new red type color and
their new they're calling it a stylet a
pen stylet stylet that just sounds cute
we'll be checking in with my sister a
little bit later because she has the 13
inch sandstone version so I would love
to do a little comparison of these
side-by-side but first let's unbox tech
Tober is here and it is great so this is
the second laptop three that's 256 gigs
of storage and 16 gigs of ram you know
what I haven't done in a while smelled
the tech that I've been unboxing I'm not
sure when I stopped doing that but for
some reason it's been a while you guys
know I'm a huge Apple fan but honestly
Microsoft Surface has been doing a
really great job at everything that
they've been coming out with for the
past couple of years like if I'm a fan
you know it's legit like their design
like everything like it just looks like
this oh my goodness they're making such
a big deal about this design because
it's so easy to open and there isn't a
little finger flap so you just like it
just opens oh I couldn't see what this
was I thought it was already on cuz it
has the instant on features so when you
open it it just automatically turns out
this looks good oh boy more things I
also liked about these is they make them
easy to access the internal
configurations so if you do need to get
an upgrade or it needs to be serviced
it's not a crazy or do you like it's
something that's super easy I don't
think that that means that you're
supposed to do it yourself I think that
means you have to take it to somebody
like Microsoft to do it for you but if
you know what you're doing how about it
thank you sure there's no other secrets
that smells like doughnuts mm-hmm so
looks like we have a USB see a regular
USB and a headphone jack I like that it
is super minimal I mean that's really
all you need
and of course over here we have our
charging port hi there
Cortana and I'm here to help a little
sign in here a touch a Wi-Fi there and
we'll have your PC ready for all you
plan to do even though I've done this
set up your voice so many times it still
gets me every time so I think I'm gonna
set them both up at the same time so
this has a 10th Gen Intel Core i5
processor with 256 gigs of storage and 8
gigs of go RAM
they have a lot of really great
accessories too like the arc mouse which
I had covered in my video that I made
before okay we're gonna set these both
up at the same time does your voice or
the keyboard along the way oh I forgot
about my surface stop I didn't think
that it was gonna close I was just
trying to the username password is
incorrect well let me try to get so I'm
not really huge fan of the color red but
I feel like this isn't really a bad red
red it's more like a version few time
colors welcome to surface pen look it's
welcoming me I'm left-handed
are you oh yeah that's beautiful so this
is pretty great so if you go faster it
makes me erase their bigger takács this
is still therapeutic I think probably
I'll just just maybe sit outside and
scribble on my surface when I'm feeling
stressed I'm so talented I'm gonna print
this out I'll settle this art printer
needs it was out of paper okay so
I printed one but then every started my
computer and I think I accidentally
printed a lot of them oh there's another
one
I'm just gonna shut my printer off I
mean this is art this is just absolute
art I mean look at this have you seen
anything better didn't think so
let's go find jenna and chat with her
and see that sandstone thirteen and a
half inch laptop it looked so good in
New York can we just get person sorry
Picasso I'm talented Jenna
[Music]
so thank you my sister she has the 13
and a half inch Sam stone color of the
surface laptop it looks really good I
know I love it beautiful okay so I can't
turn my neck because I fell asleep on a
boat yesterday and my neck was like this
it happens when you get all with people
so that's what we put you over here
because I'm over here I can turn this
way oh you want me to get it for you no
I have it
I hurt my neck turning very fast because
I'm from Tyler was in the back seat he's
behind the camera and he said something
about mac and cheese and what for my
neck around and I also hurt my neck but
I'm better now I'm healed
every night RT also just drink a sprite
that was expired from like 2017 I
haven't even have spread in 20 years and
that's doc yeah this time you've had one
what are we doing today oh well you're
gonna be just chatting about our surface
laptops it's have a surface 17 matching
style X Oh
Bragi I thought we would do a little
drawing challenge oh no it'll be kind of
like charades okay do you remember when
I drank this this from 2007 I don't
drink that
so to start off our drawing challenge
which I'm not gonna go first Tyler's
going to text for something to draw and
then I'm gonna guess what it is oh my
gosh this is very exciting I think
Tyler's thinking what to text me I'm
seeing everything I'm a really bad
artist no no I know I don't know how to
draw that what's it look like how much
does it draw that Tyler elephant I
haven't done anything um mmm
macaroni and cheese pot cauldron martini
am I supposed to say things that's a bad
drawing oh I want to start over
look at all this space I could have been
utilizing tracer if you turn it over
it's incredible okay all right Marty
shut up Oh a high-speed shot this is
part of the game oh that's a nice thick
boy so starting right it normally
there's a timer but I think at this okay
let's start I'm ready now
okay okay ready martini ice cream
martini chocolate martini Maddy martini
Oh I need to add a colony of our
teammate macaroni machete macaroni
drowning macaroni
drawing spider worms banana see what
they look like they mealworms Oh mache
macaronis this will help goldfish shrimp
cocktail this is like if a newborn just
straight came out and gave it like a
surface was a cure draw I'm sure you're
done now you'll have the drawing that
was 2 minutes
now instead of our lives will never get
I can't believe that bad I had to look
at up a shrimp cocktail I don't eat
shrimp why don't I know what that looks
like my computer is still updating so as
soon as we update it'll be my turn see
you've got your like shrimp
I know lines really dope it did it
really did and then I realized that
those were eyes do they have eyes oh
yeah they have eyes
I don't eat meat or fish so how do we
win the game
there's this is that's I don't know my
surface is all updated and I'm ready to
draw for Jenna it can't be anything
worse than what I did if you want to
pick a new food let me keep it there
yeah maybe keep it fair I guess Jenna
likes food food okay looking for candy
that's why I drink a spoiled bright cuz
I'm gonna sweet I wanted it's probably
very flat oh my god oh my gosh okay I
hope it's like pizza but that's way too
easy
banana circle oatmeal potato chip french
fry waffle fry potato chip
absolutely not Pringle oh that's the
wrong color on color this is something I
would eat a pickle
Elise maybe I'm not good at drawing
either Oh me corn I see it now corn on
the cob porn
this is toy it's really not good trim
cocktails way better sounds really bad
David she couldn't get it why not cuz I
look like a potato chip without the
green it look like a potato kinda look
like a buttered bun nope where I draw
the butter if you hit back it look like
a potato chip cherries I didn't do
anything yet cherry pie cherry biscuit
at risk so it's hard to draw because I
that's white isn't it
why are you doing runway cherry kale
salad Caesar salad chili chili stew pot
pie bacon skillet camping potion sushi I
was gonna drop chopsticks ya know you
don't ya you do how else do you drive
sushi oh my god Jenna has never had
sushi she's barely this means you keep
getting me with the fish look a little
cold a little spicy tuna action okay now
Tyler has to think of another food group
are you looking on Google the food did
she know but a lot of food looks like
I'm hurt culture maybe I'll just draw
spaghetti to move on
[Music]
salmon a hat ham turkey it looks like
smokey the Bears hatch a hamburger
cheeseburger
it's world cheese tomato soup we're done
I started over okay new picture circle a
circle pumpkin pie pie pie is it pie is
that a type of pie I'm gonna go as a
type of pie
so pot hole chicken pot pie good thing
that we can like communicate
passionately or else we would a bitter
for a very long time
okay no fair
really Oh what does a guy look like cuz
that's terrible all freakin ambulance a
problem pot five like a child
trying to draw a planet oh my god
honestly that was like record time I
could've been your room I know I think
you probably won so Jenna wanna get one
honestly I mean this is your
illustrations were actually better than
mine so one of my favorite things about
Windows 10 is you can play a lot of Xbox
games so they have cross compatibility
with a bunch of titles you can also hook
up an Xbox controller so the new Xbox
elite controller came out I didn't do an
unboxing this so I thought I would try
it oh my god I have a pain so I thought
that I would tie in an unboxing to my
surface
I'm gonna be in like a physical therapy
room for my next video because I'm not
well they should play games and work on
your drawing
I still have tears in my eyes from this
pot pie like you're incredible
no I'm just I can read people's mind I
mean no I can't don't don't ask me about
my special sound so let's take a peek at
this I'm so excited about this we saw it
at e3 Jenna already has his own box and
our happiness like this I love this so
you can charge them all to the case I
didn't know that that I do not know so
I'm actually yeah cool design can I put
mine back in I mean the first one was so
and that makes sense I took it out of
the case because I didn't realize you
could charge it in the gate yeah that's
pretty cool alright well we're gonna
play some games on Jenna's channel for
her surface video and where's the one
game we're gonna play one game on
Jenna's over her service video so make
sure you guys go head over and check out
hers she doesn't unboxing oh this is the
surface right here it's Ernie oh I'm
wanting to call it blush so I've had to
edit out so many times in myself calling
it a blush color but it is Sam's Jones
yeah beautiful see you guys later and if
you ever want me to draw something for
you I'm starting with a commissioned
page I think that it's really something
that you should get it as a gift for
your loved ones okay bye it's a really
bad pain I think I have I think I have a
bad injury Jim you know oh and I even
took advil so like nothing has helped
okay I guess we could stop the video now
[Music]